ya know welcome to this video started
this is a new three minute madness video
we have how to get some madness i King
zinan it's not entirely mad but I want
to keep it in with in some kind of
reason at least don't exchange place
that would be a big non-starter for
excitement the exchange variation yeah
try to be quick I will see 5 years early
I haven't really don't know that line I
have looked at it but provides and a
long time ago huh yeah it looks like
white is a bit better yet I don't like
your chick with a deep on allowing a
queen trait which rate is not ready in
the spirit of this of this video but I
didn't really see what I have to do okay
so at least we don't trade queens this
is not yet yeah very weird position the
Knights on age 68 age for the maker and
absolutely weird impression yeah check
wants to trade here understand the blame
hmm and I said that's not ideal for
excitement and also not a very good
position yeah okay not much to do I
still i mean i don't think it's terrible
for black because pennant White's
position also has some downsides so do I
go at five now like opening up the whole
thing no one but I think I can take and
go out five here right this is this is
getting interesting okay so what about
this this is a tech but I want to
activate him maybe get to be to pawn
what problem is if he takes be six is
that didn't think about that move at all
it takes b6 there is some as some issues
with them the deep on okay
huh ok ok I have to play move some so at
some time just keeps this ok
night coming to wear f4 and so on i
would donate f3 as a thread right
cannot cover that
Bishop age six time warning that's a
fork III King f1 yeah it's not so
convincing let's get let's get the
department and now I want to pass up I
don't get get it with this yeah okay
I'll keep the upon their check white
resides yeah it wasn't like the to
madness star but at least I go to
winning let's have a new game against d
for its kind of tricky that there is no
really okay maybe the banker but there
is no valid gambit that you can play
maybe best tries for exciting chest
dutch defense or the Kings Indian I mean
I want to play something that is
completely bonkers but maybe I should
like the albums okay give me a new game
I actually clicked for them and for me
check three-minute again let's get going
yeah he kind of lost control there the
position was certainly better white him
that game against XL 200 gain started
Rhett kit okay I can't deserve
Grandmaster right who is that new name
but okay I can try for the Aldens but
you and it usually doesn't work against
against the strong player they all know
now that a three is good yeah this is
what happens if wide noses theory why it
is just better now I mean it's not like
losing why you think but white is better
let's see however I mean it still seems
like it's a playable position wonder if
that was the best choice that he took
them yeah this is not super exciting
which I tried to get the Albin's but you
don't get any excitement as I said if
the other guy knows his stuff okay go
back
ok be six is a bad idea I'd be this one
nice good babies go to you for now okay
it's not it's not fatal
b6 maybe I probably have to take on c5
mm that's not so bright maybe just be 64
wide now it takes a long time you okay
this one yeah it's quite clearly a move
I didn't really think about it you can
take b7 now there's no probably no
substantial reason why you cannot do
that take on b7 ok I have to have to do
that ok so how to get some counterplay
going maybe this nice got King youtube
ok I thought King into it grabbing is of
course very valid
check it's not so easy after the rook
trade for him to to get this get this
mobile here I win this bone back nice
ideas to play like ook at five and
bishops in three yeah rook e8 probably
you know so we're checking doesn't
really help much and now he's got like a
that doesn't really look at five I was
thinking but I Scotty five stupid didn't
think about it time morning okay maybe
that wasn't a big deal
yeah I have a play Bishop a six he has
the secretary sacrifice as possibly
coming up right sir uncomfortable
definitely is uncomfortable check check
try the check nice one check nice one
okay yeah it is not fun I mean the
Alvin's is just a bad opening it's what
it is okay if someone attacked someone
knows stuff you just worse okay I mean I
wasn't so worse in this game but it was
always uncomfortable somehow okay let's
fire with the Kings gambit Knight to d7
huh okay that's a good line moderate
line yeah I tried to get the porn back
at least I seems that he just gives me
the porn huh okay
hmm ok that's it so bad you should
reform maybe and lets us prevent this
it's a little bit slow but I don't want
even more pressure on the pawn yes this
is a move hmm yeah what was very stupid
I was a very stupid decision okay check
okay I was more afraid that he takes I
know I get quite strong compensation
here I was more afraid that he takes my
bishop does this position isn't bad at
all yeah I was a very strange decision
not to take my bishop
yeah now it just gets completely killed
I'm just a queen up here a little bit
surprised that you continues this check
check check black resign ok next one he
says thank you well yeah I can be also
very grateful that he didn't took take
my bishop here taking the bishop p.m.
would have reduced my attacking
potential so much yeah I don't think I
have anything there ok give me a new
game
yeah maybe black against you form that
would be good get quite a bit of more
more enterprising option than against
deform fortunately takes a while gain
started early on ok wgm with that let's
check all gone yeah Shekinah don't know
her yeah can we get this the model line
with d5 which is a good line on I'm
happy happy to take it check ok I don't
know h3 h3 might not be that brilliant
maybe I can get the Queen over to h4
quickly the big problem in this kind of
position is that mean for white is that
this point f4 is so obstructing you
cannot develop easily and sometimes a
knight can jump into you three um yeah
95 yeah it looks very very brute yeah
brutal is wrong very very crude crude is
the right word
and cannot take when I for maybe this
one threatening 95 now I can take
actually that doesn't look too bad
actually pawn up each six Wow
okay so i take this let's take this
there should be some kind of something
good here rook f6 maybe I couldn't have
six is still playable I can just go back
but that looks kind of meek don't see
anything brilliant so I'll go back yeah
this movie this is a bit irritating I
don't have a good square here that's bad
this is not ideal at all night coming to
reform would be hugely irritating time
morning okay no 94 wow that stuff going
on f7 is cuz he's got it covered or
she's got it covered I'm sorry hmm
that's kind of weird
my night only 3m needs to get into the
game really really badly yeah this
should be three nights you form and i
only got 38 seconds it's also a problem
you still 90 form
37 seconds ok at least I have a clear
plan wow she's not doing anything
against that that's weird surprising now
I'm just ruining the house 497 check
yeah now that wasn't a good position but
Kings gambit proof to be irritating
enough check cannot promote right check
yeah she really wants to play this to
the bitter end check check check check
black for fits fine kind jam there
wasn't a good position I did was tricky
or still kind of difficult to handle ok
next one I'm on fifty percent I think
roughly in the session or let's say I
keep my reading which is good
considering the Becky openings gain
starting and thus fighter that's a good
rule that's a good player yeah ok let's
let's go for the Dutch maybe yeah
yeah I know that efore there's as rook
age seven which is completely wacky I
have the feeling if I try that that I'm
going to lose the game it got this this
is such a weird position but it's
supposed to be playable now black tries
to win this this Bishop it has to yeah
he has to do this in order not to
getting killed immediately okay yes 95 I
wish I seen but i def 626 do I have to
go g 60 s good Bishop g5 wow how do I
not Lucy I really have no idea about
this it looks terrible okay
Bishop g5 I thought I can take on a form
i wonder what Bishop c4 just e6 I guess
now i have to write and now howdy five
what kind of position is that I know
this is a line I mean this is not it's
made me crazy i 95 radisson unbelievable
okay well maybe there's two bishops
hanging so maybe I'm winning one of the
bishops at least Wow
the only really good situation is the
clock situation I'm really a lot ahead
on the clock okay if it takes f7
communities okay I have to go see six I
need to have a detect I cannot play
anything else and he just goes back ok
so I'll take it and then yes Bishop just
six or what no I can take F to hear if
you take c6 not sure what it that if it
helps much but I can I can take ok I can
take care now hmm let's have a look here
can I get rid of this somehow it's got
rookie one
check this is f 5 is kind of hanging not
sure if I mean I think I should should
cover it check ya King be 60 time
morning
okay probably and want to trade queens
just do it yeah I can't read Queens
though almost almost if for it's not a
clean trade wow this is totally crazy
Bishop f4 coming up yeah okay c5 is a
check but i have c 7 okay so grab this
and by now i'm i'm up a ton of material
but we're having time I have no time
whatsoever completely I didn't didn't
check the time check Wow check Wow check
check check check dodging bullets here
check check shoot back god damn it is
winning this stunt time this nonsense no
I getting the Queen check check check
check
no damn it no he's got one pond if they
don't believe it I was just about to
take it no what it came what a game oh
my goodness poo oh ok thanks game yeah
this is what it's all about I was just
about to take and just about to take the
last born I actually had it in and it
had entered the move already pre mooted
rather than I poo yeah one more game
game started Wow had a very high-rez guy
infernal exam okay who is that Pavel
peccato 2607 okay he's playing that the
staunton gambit Staunton gambit ya see
696 they're both quite viable
interesting okay that says let's just
keep the pawn down and let's see where
his compensation is maybe yeah okay
Queen f6 maybe just takes it and place
for compensation upon with Queens off
it's possible it's very possible ot 6
why did that play the bishop somewhere
hmm okay
now I was mindlessly played really i
plated absolutely terribly should I
should have just thought a little bit I
mean I think it's still ok but it could
have been a lot lawton not bad
not easy to call in atl point and don't
want to play the move but i don't see
what else actually preparing to take
only four maybe okay check
you know what's really a problem I'm
thinking the whole time I'm thinking I'm
a pawn up and they were thinking whom it
said really that brilliant hear him I
mean he's got compensation without any
doubt but yeah I was thinking it might
not be such a big deal and I would know
he has given me a pawn why did he do
that no I'm just keeping keeping this
special to do six check okay i might
have six and I'm a pawn down I'm not a
pawn down I'm coming I miscounting you
the whole game is a story of Miss
counting my pawns time morning is really
weird
hi this is nonsense I'm just blundering
b6 and he doesn't take it now i'm done
doing ce-5 check and disturb it takes a
check check check check check check
sorry little hope in
check check don't see a clear way yet
for him to win probably bazoobs one also
check check okay so he has no clear way
to win now it's just as wrong in we went
on time very lucky I got blundering the
plan but the problem was the time I
couldn't I couldn't who would that do to
the time track position is just to draw
was just a draw check black 415 hi ok I
think it was a good session nevertheless
that that game in Dutch against endless
fight I was out of this world ok i hope
you enjoyed this crazy session thanks
for watching